το καλοκαίρι για μ έναν είναι περιμένω πως και πός η τώρα εαι χειρότερι μου
περρίως να ξε η τώρα από ξέρω ότι το καλοκαίρι ναργή οπότε να ειρεμία εμέναν
έρχεται με την επαφή με τη θάλασσα όταν έρχει το καλοκαίρι γυρεύω αφορμές να εξαφανίζομε
απογεύματααυτό να πηγαίνουμε κάποιο τρόπος θαότο κυρία κανα είμαι κοντά στη θάλασα και επειδή κλίνουνη
αυτή η ζήτηση θε θελα νατελικό μήνυμα του σιόο τιςτα προς τους πολίτες οι οποίοι
σίγουρα έχουν ανάγκη η τεχνολογί αν έχουν ανάγκη τις επικοινωνίες τι να περιμένουν για το
αύριο να ξενομίζω ζούμε σε μια εποχή του κινισμού και της μιζέριας δούμε σε μια
εποχίο όπου ακούμε πάρα πολλύ αρνητική ενέργεια να έρχεται να μας βρίσκει και χρειάζεται όλοι
μας να γίνουμε θετικές δνάμεις πρέπα γίνουμε περισσότερο θετική από ότι είμαστε για το καλόν
όλον α και ιδικότερα για το καλό της χώρας εγώ νιώθο ησίτα τα τελευταία χρόνια
έχει πετίχι αυτό το πράμα να είναι μια δναμη θετικής αλλαγής έναν παράδειγμα το οποίο
δίνι λέει και στους άλλους ότι μπορούμε να κάνουμε κάποια παράγματα δεν είναι αδύνατο δυστυχώς
δεν άκου δεν έχουμε πολλά τέτοια παραδειγμάτα το μίνυμα αν είναι ότι ας δούμε τη
κανησίτα και ος προσπαθίσουμε όλοι μας να πειτύχουμε το κάτι παραπάνο να μην είμαστε ο
μέσως ώρος να μην θεωρούμε επίτευμα να μην είμαστε ντελευταίοι αλλάνα είμαστε κορηθεί να στοχεύουμε
ψηλά και νομίζω η κύπρος έχει πάρα πολλές δυνατότητες ησίτα έδειξε να πλά σε έναν
τομέα που ενώτο μέσεις τεχνολογίας ο οποίος μπορεία και πουτους πιο δύσκολους τοομίς έδειξεν ότι
γίνεται ένα